is that Braden it is mark McGrath from
the band sugar rain off the charts
sugar egg this the the just off rip the
like the it's not like a lack of
motivation but it's like a sugar a you
knows like there's pain well he's doing
it like a radio host almost yeah what's
Brayden it's mark McGrath here from
Sugar Ray he said it up [ __ ] billion
times true yet this is probably like his
eight million cameo that he's doing yeah
today yeah
just ripping through them and he gets to
this one it what's Brayden he probably
started it without even reading the
[ __ ] come on yeah and then he got to
and he's like oh [ __ ] he's already in it
let's go but always in your hearts this
like he had that prepped what do you say
off the charts but always in your hearts
oh my man has done too much radio yeah
he's done way too much radio Cheyenne
and she wants you to know a few things
and this is a little difficult for me to
say because it's the first one of these
I've done but she wants you to know that
you mean a lot to her
you mean the Walter her uh-oh anytime
someone starts with you mean a lot to me
[ __ ] just say it you I mean you know
this guy's face what he looked like when
he was listening he got to this point
he's like oh what's about to happen I
know something's not right here I
receive all yeah she wants you to know
you mean a lot to her mark cut this [ __ ]
just say it dude cut the [ __ ] [ __ ]
and he's just as he's talking he's like
that's a breakup at the end of that
paragraph because I don't want to hear
all this other [ __ ] but she's having
difficulty staying in this long-distance
relationship you know it's tough I've
been on the road for years and I've been
with my wife a long time and the biggest
arguments the biggest you know obstacles
in our relationships is the distance
bro ours worked out yeah yeah we've been
fortunately not the case yeah you guys
yeah see my wife married for 25 years
made it through very brutal touring
periods the yeah the distance was hard
but we made it yeah I'm just saying I
can relate because we've also fought but
in the end she loved me enough to stay
with me but back to you guys Cheyenne
she wants to know about that a fart
always in her heart
Cheyenne however wants to [ __ ] other man
my wife loyal loyal yeah always has been
always will be shy Cheyenne Cheyenne
thinks that she should see other people
that's all it says I'm sorry that's all
the Cameo says it makes it very
difficult around the road and it's hard
so Cheyenne is trying to like Gino
brain-dead it's very very tough for her
to stay in this relationship because her
TA and her current masters program is
really attractive more than you and
she's having a really hard time just not
doing it
it's just weirdly more and more specific
did she met a dude named Brendan at a
bookstore and she thought he was really
cute okay and turns out they were into
the exact same literature and he was
really smart and a guy comes in with a
bucket of diarrhea and lo and behold
Brendan is there to save her so now she
feels a little bit of a mmm connection
because he was there to protect her and
you were not yeah so sorry always in her
heart she still cares about you a lot
you never know what the future may hold
and she oh I wonder if she was like
minute what the [ __ ] this is over
hey bro keep your head up dude
you know maybe in the future you might
get uses ad-libbing
you never know the future might hold
man maybe you just got a move out there
and prove your love to her mark I didn't
pay for this [ __ ] no mark refund now
this looked it you you [ __ ] man he's
on his way here now he's on a train
still wants to be friends with you
because obviously she cares about you
very very much she wants you to know yes
it cares so much that she hired mark
McGrath to dump you
yeah that's what I'm saying dude you
know what's funny is like this is like a
bit you know I [ __ ] I've made this
joke to people I'm sure there's a sketch
out there somewhere a service where
people will do breakups for you and
handle that [ __ ] for you
this is [ __ ] it yeah like it's just
things as higher mark McGrath yeah to do
it but like I don't so what I don't get
is that like you know when I'm doing
cameos it's like it's like my boyfriend
and I watch your videos every day please
wish him happy birthday this would mean
a lot yeah so what what would you have
to do with Sugar Ray for your boyfriend
to love or hate maybe mark McGrath's so
much that this would be appropriate I
think it's a sugar ray is the song yeah
is the band they were listening to and
it hooked up for the first time so it's
like it's a nice little bow tie yeah
start it every morning I'm sorry this
doesn't usually happen I swear it's
usually no no but usually I'm good it
doesn't
I usually last longer than this my mom
she thought it'd be a nice little you
know yeah started here and let's end it
here good luck on your thesis coming up
cold cold
he's doing his thesis and you pick now
he just he says that way keep I know he
changes his D yeah no this is next
comment is hilarious but there's a
majesty I being like he just gets that
points I know you're working on her
thesis just cuts to him like deleting
his previous thesis his new thesis why
all women or the devil and as old thesis
is why I love my girlfriend I'm writing
a thesis about how awesome my girlfriend
is Cheyenne that's where he realized he
should not have done this one right
there that [ __ ] face he's like this
is Jesus geez rut ro what do you do with
these yes but I understand this D says
is this yes his thesis you know you
gotta work on your thesis and life goes
on and but you know you got to work on
your thesis and life goes on man for a
long time with a lot of pain [ __ ] man
bad timing and you know I'm sure there's
big things ahead of you in the future
Braden but Cheyenne cares about you
enough to let you know that she's
thinking about you but the long-distance
thing is just a little difficult oh my
god the way he's praising it she's
thinking about you dude this reads like
getting fired by someone who doesn't
know why you were fired yeah exactly
you know it's um did the paper says it's
uh it's just it's not a personal it's
just a performance thing that's all I
have on the paper yeah
did any other questions perhaps about
your severance you just want to know why
you were fine yeah I can't
I can't I'm sorry you seem like a nice
guy is she she really she wants to let
you know that she's she's really
thinking about you and she cares enough
about you to let you know that this
isn't working through hey mark McGrath
just probably stuck in another day
no but she cares about you and she wants
you to stay positive she wants you to be
friends and she knows that you're a fan
of the band Sugar Ray which I'm honored
I wish I'd imagined saying stay positive
to someone you're breaking up with that
dude do or done but just stay positive
okay did she give him knuckles with that
- hey you know what hang in there
you're gonna make it you're gonna be
fine you're gonna be just fine I can
tell I know I know cuz we did it we
dated you're a great guy I know you're a
great guy from personal experience
you're gonna make it dude yeah just keep
the high I yeah hi ketta not the low I
keep the high I keep the high not the
low I'm gonna be fine
see if this whole experience doesn't
tickle you a little bit I think you want
to go on a walk could take a little
check in with the M&E hot swell up so
it's just Matthew McConaughey's breakup
cameos just way long does the dough make
any sense and just listen Cheyenne wants
to have the monologue without the
dialogue now listen Braden if I can call
you that
you spent a lot of time with Cheyenne
she got a little thing she wants tell
you you're just staring at it like come
on hurry the [ __ ] up
well let's let mark finish I gotta hear
the rest of this ooh good news hopefully
I can see you backstage give you a
high-five someday dude we can maybe
laugh about this sometime oh [ __ ] hey
what you know man we might hang out
backstage one time and we could totally
you know man I got broken up with in a
cameo and all I got was this [ __ ]
backstage Sugar Ray yes I can't think of
any scenario worse after this then all
three of them hanging out ruin you paid
me to break up with him Oh what is what
a zany time they're just sitting at
opposing ends of the table just like
this and he's like so guys this is
awkward he's like trying to do the same
[ __ ] he's like well we could say the
distance is close now maybe there is a
chance of love here like one of those
shitty [ __ ] what's that YouTube
channel that does like the did the just
against a white backdrop and they're
both just sitting in chairs like [ __ ]
four feet from each other just like he's
like well how's your thesis got to start
a dialogue
nothing friends right now bro the
long-distance things a little difficult
but she wishes you nothing but the best
all the love in the world and do do
do do your best on that thesis man I
know it's now it's a season and
relationships and all that stuff man but
you've got big things ahead of you bro
if you're working on a thesis you've got
a good life in front of you all right
on behalf of mark McGrath and Cheyenne
we love you Braden be positive bro
all right do do do do do not kill
yourself do do do do do do do not jump
in front of a train police
you